okay.
This is serious and this relates to last night's
debate.
We already talked about the debate performance.
We talked about Mike Bloomberg getting eaten
alive, clearly didn't make his his billions
debating, that's for sure.
We talked about the very clear divisions between
the Progressive's and the centrist during
last night's debate, but we have to talk about
our democracy.
When we talk about our system of democracy
in the United States, we will often point
out the flaws of the electoral college system
where Republican presidents have frequently
lost the popular vote.
More people voted for their opponent, but
yet they became president of the United States
2016 and Donald Trump is an example.
This happened with George W. Bush.
We've talked about this before.
A similar dynamic exists in the democratic
nomination process wherein you can have a
plurality of pledge delegates going into the
democratic national convention, more delegates
than anybody else, but you can end up not
being the nominee when superdelegates typically
party insiders and elected officials get to
vote on this time in the second round of DNC
voting.
This came up at last night's debate.
There was one person on the stage who said,
I believe that whoever has the most delegates
should be the nominee.
That was Bernie Sanders.
Every other candidate said, we should follow
the system.
We should follow the rules of the DNC.
Take a look at this video
and I want to ask all of you this simple question.
There's a very good chance and none of you
are going to have enough delegates to the
democratic national convention to clinch this
nomination.
Okay?
If that happens, I want all of your opinions
on this.
Should the person with the most delegates
at the end of this primary season be the nominee,
even if they are short of a majority?
Senator Sanders, I'm gonna let you go last
year because I know your view on this.
So instead I will start with you, mayor Bloomberg.
Whatever the rules for the democratic party
are, they should be followed.
And if they have a process, which I believe
I'm trying to do, everybody can do you want
the convention to work?
It's, well, yes, Senator Warren, but a convention
working in swell means that people have the
delegates that are pledged to them and they
keep those delegates until the leading convention.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Vice president Biden
play by the rules are now leading person with
the delegate.
Should they be the nominee or not?
Let the process work its way out.
Mayor budaj not necessarily.
Not until there Senator Klobuchar met the
process work.
Senator Sanders.
Well, the process includes 500 super-delegates
on the second ballot, so I think that the
will of the people.
Sure.
Yes.
Thank you guys that yes, this
is not a trivial issue.
Not only because it goes to the core of what
does it mean to reflect the will of the people,
but this is not a trivial issue because this
is increasingly likely to be the scenario.
We already know that if Bernie keeps getting
25 or 30% of the vote in primaries, he likely
will not have 50% of the delegates.
The way the math works, you can get 50% of
the delegates without 50% of the vote.
We did this yesterday.
If you are in the 35 to 38 ish range, percent
of the vote, depending on how many viable
candidates there are, that is enough to get
50% of the delegates.
But if Bernie stays around 28 to 31 it's very
likely he won't get 1,991 delegates.
Case in point, the five 30 eight.com estimate
right now says that the most likely scenario
is one in which nobody gets to 50% plus one
of the delegates.
There's a 40% probability of that Bernie getting
50% plus one has a 37% probability, no other
scenario gets past 11% now the DNC increasingly
knows this.
The candidates on the stage increasingly know
this and this is the strategy to deny Bernie
the nomination.
So what every candidate on that stage is saying
is, I don't think that if you enter the convention
with the most delegates, you should be the
nominee.
They are saying, no matter who gets the most
delegates, superdelegates should have their
say and the DNCs completely flawed process
is what gets to decide.
And by the way, what they're also sort of
saying is, and I hope you'll pick me when
that time comes, Bernie is saying the will
of the people should determine who the nominee
is.
It's very simple.
Nobody else is saying that on the stage.
And what this certainly reveals is that the
candidates themselves are all but conceding.
Bernie will get the most delegates, but it's
a boldfaced attempt to try to sort of cross
their fingers, say I stand by the system,
I'm in line and hope that the DNC will pick
them to be the nominees when Bernie fails
to get to 1,991 delegates.
Now I've been consistent on this from day
one.
This is not about any individual candidates
policy.
I don't think we should have an electoral
college system nationally and I don't think
we should have a delegate system for the nomination.
That includes superdelegates at any point
in time.
Now at the national level, we can get around
the electoral college without a big constitutional
amendment through something called the national
popular vote interstate compact.
And what that, the way that works is if enough
States say, we will give our electors to whoever
wins the popular vote.
If enough States such that their total number
of electoral votes totals two 70 without changing
the constitution, you have a defacto national
popular vote.
We know the path to that nationally for the
DNC system to change.
The DNC needs to agree to change it.
Why would they do that when this is how they
retain some degree of control over who the
nominee is, regardless of the will of the
people?
It's an uphill battle for sure.
This was a very telling moment from last night's
debate, and one that without a doubt is going
to be consequential in terms of who ultimately
is the nominee and something we're going to
be watching very closely in terms of numbers
as the delegates start to be a portion on
the basis of voting.
Let's take a quick break.
Make sure you're following the David Passman
show on Instagram
at David